hey yes what's up this is andrew for
jensens.com
so this is day number six for me in my
friends in hotel
and it's monday morning in hong kong and
i'm about to make an update guys
on amc and gamestop together in the same
video
i would like in this video to take a
little step back to you know just
remind us what is the situation and go
with you quickly through how i find my
targets
uh what are my different scenarios and
what technical analysis is giving us for
the coming week
so let's get into it
[Music]
so let's start with amc so
here as i said we take a step back we go
on the first time frame
and just look at it guys all right look
at it
so i remind you what happened here amc
went in 25 went to 25 in january
strongly corrected to five guys so this
was a
deep correction and then here we had
a new high correction again and finally
here we broke
this level around 10 so uh remember guys
i was telling you
like it's time to go amc is going to
blow up
you know because we had this breakout
then here we had this retest
that was a bit for me a bad trap i
remind you because we went
lower than the 78.6 retracement level of
the fib retracements
so for a second wave it is too low
usually
uh so for me this was a bit tricky but
there was this
retro line that supported the price
action this is the reason why i remained
here
bullish and i told you that we're gonna
have a very strong move up to 35
then that we're going to get rejected we
would go to 65.75 and guess this is what
happened so just a quick reminder to
tell you
that all of this was kind of expected
and then i told you guys that we're
gonna have a deeper correction all right
so this is expected two guys and the
fifth wave is
expected too all right so just a quick
reminder now let's discuss this
correction
that is i have to say a bit deeper than
i expected in the first place i was
seeing here a triangle that got broken
around the 48 areas and when it got
broken that would you guys be careful
now you know we're going to 35 38 you
know all this area is basically the top
of the third
and the recent close that we had here we
went there
and from there we strongly rebounded and
then i told you that below 45
it's not looking good and right now the
question is
where is this correction heading and
when is it going to be complete and what
are the different scenarios for the
coming week so once again i took this
step back yes to show you that usually
full suede they like to connect to the
top of the third
which is 37 you know this area or the
bottom of the force which is 24
so you don't need to have you know a
crazy model like i know some youtubers
are using that gives you you know those
level like 32
24 you know 24 is just the bottom of the
force you know you don't need a model
it's a basic support level
and 32 this level you can find it
different ways it's not a level i had
in my analysis in the first place so
it's still interesting you know to
afterwards see
where it's coming from so i gave you
this level actually but a bit
later i gave it to you i think like just
on my discord
just the day before we actually reached
it and i just connected here guys the
laws that i have between so we see
better on that only
the laws that i had between my first
wave and
my third wave here so up see between
this one
here and this one so bam i just do this
and
you find 32 you can also find 32 by
using another method that is
you know very classic once again you
don't need a crazy model to do this
up you just measure the wave between
the third wave so between here and here
and
you can see that it give us 32.9 so
maybe 33 but the 61.8
retracement so once again guys fourth
and second waves
as long as there are zigzags all right
it's not true for flats i'm going to
make a full course on this as well for
now i just did my elliott wave course so
you can click on the link in description
of this video you're gonna receive it
for free you're gonna access the member
zone where i'm gonna put all my
trainings later and here those zigzag
corrections
they like to go to the 50 or 61.8
percent retracement
so what are those levels oh funny so 40
and
32.9 all right so those are my levels
for the field retracement so this is
another way to find 32
but once again just be careful because
fibs they give you
areas all right it's not precise support
levels if you want some precision you
need to use trend lines
just like we did here for example with
gesture line you have precision
and when it's broken you know that it's
going to become resistance this kind of
stuff
so it's very useful to use so we went to
32 for now now
let me combine guys to my different
scenarios that once again i gave you on
my discord i gave some associate
probabilities so the most likely
scenario
is that here we bounce back at 24 and we
go to 42
something like this and we get rejected
to complete a fifth why
am i a bit bearish around the 42 area
and why am i bullish
during this for the coming week so i
have answers
for both questions all right so when you
go on a 30 minutes time frame
you can see that we're having some
bullish divergences
here so it's the hidden buddhist
divergences so macd going lower price
action going lower uh macd going higher
sorry
price action going lower you can find
those you know so you just connect the
lows and you check
the momentum is going higher and you can
find those on the 15 minutes
on the 30 minutes and on the hourly it
disappear
so a very interesting tip i want to give
you here guys
in this video is you might be wondering
but for how long is this divergence
impacting the price action
and i have an answer for this it's
empirical it's from my experience
this you will not not find this anywhere
in any book
but i'm telling you guys this you can
see by yourself you can trust me
whatever
this is only my experience and basically
this divergence will impact the price
action
roughly between the period between the
lows so
here 8th of july 15th of july right so
roughly one week between those two lows
where we find the divergence so
basically it's going to have an impact
for one or two weeks
so this is why here we have this move up
and i think we still this divergent is
still impacting the price action
until here but after here it's not
impacting the price action anymore and
we need to see if we have
longer term divergences which we don't
guys so here we still have some weakness
all right 502 hours time frame
what is the momentum doing going down
all right so
this is the reason why for now i will
not turn bullish even if we go to 40
right i will not turn bullish i will all
need to unbolish if we go to 40
if i see a breakout so once again just
like we had here guys
this is what you're looking for right
and i gave you this trade guys
on my discord i know that some of you
made some money by
using this information so i'm glad it
helped basically we had the breakout
here i was telling you guys don't rush
don't form wait for the retest we're
gonna have the retest few hours later we
got it
three hours after i said that it was
here and then of course we moved higher
and then i had
a price target of 40 to 43 it's still
holding for me
but be careful guys this is what is
invalidating my scenario
all right we need to make kind of a flat
you know
something like this so basically if we
trade below
31.5 this scenario is invalidated even
on a 15 minute time frame and
if we have a break of the 34 levels on
the hourly timeframe it's not good as
well there is
70 80 chance we go lower right away
and that we don't do the c wave all
right it's still possible the zigzag is
here this is one
of my other scenarios all right and that
the fourth one is like this but it's
unlikely i think the first one
will go here at least so let's find out
let's see so i gave you here everything
i could i think
guys and then yeah if we go to 24 of
course
it's still bullish guys and 24 is an
amazing level to buy right it's the
bottom of the force it's a typical
field retracement uh no it's not a field
retracement level 32 was one
24 is a bit low is the 78.6
so this could be one of the tricks the
market gave us
for example here it's possible as well
for this second wave that went to the
same field retracement as far as i'm
concerned i would here be
very bullish and i'm not scared to go to
24
not at all i think it would be a very
nice level for more liquidity to step in
in the game and help the price action to
move higher very quickly guys
i want to show you this once again this
is adoption of an interest some of you
when i
did a video when i only put the word
options in the title
i had a lot of comments saying yeah
don't um don't talk about options it's
not good for eggs
all right guys i know that a lot of you
lost a lot of money on options i'm an
ex-option shredder guys so i know how
difficult to trade these instruments can
be
once you know how it works it's actually
not that complicated
the strategies i'm giving in my videos
there are zero premium strategies guys
all right
which means you cannot lose money with
the time passing you know it's not like
buying calls but
i need to tell you that this is
something that amc price actually needs
to get my squeeze all right if you have
those higher strike
open interest that get bigger and bigger
and bigger
this is going to create a lot of bullish
momentum in the price action let me show
you once again here
i rebuild everything myself once again i
think up and up
the option open interest from yahoo
finance i copy paste it here i use my
vlookup functions you know
i used to use bloomberg for that but i
don't have my bluemix access anymore for
now
i'm gonna get it back soon nowhere and i
compute all
the synthetic short by using the delta
black shoes formula
and i come up here with the synthetic
shot of six percent of the tuples for
sure and you can see that if we go to 70
we only go to nine percent from six to
nine percent do you see it well guys
and guys we used to be at 20 here guys
all right so this is
not a lot so i would be happy to see
those call options open interest growing
so it's kind of a sacrifice that maybe
some
would do of course they don't aim to
sacrifice
but i know that this is costing money i
know that some people
lose money in it but i'm still telling
you that you want to see those open
uh interest growing on the upside
because this is what is going to create
fear amongst the sellers they're going
to be
more likely to buy shares when amc would
go higher
so this is creating momentum this is
current creating
a gamma squeeze so for now we're not
having a lot guys so this is another
reason that
i'm not so convinced we're going to
break 4042
right away maybe we need one more time
but i'm still very bullish on the long
run of course now gamestop
quickly what do we have here so same
story guys
here let me remind you that we are
exactly in the situation amc was not
that long ago guys all right
we broke the major resistance level that
became support
and here we are re-testing this trend
line just like amc did here guys
this situation is what is happening with
gamestop but with gamestop everything is
bigger guys everything is bigger
this first wave is measuring more than
100 percent
imc's one was around 40 i think
so you see everything is bigger so we
are set up maybe to even
stronger moves so let's see just
technically this is to me still
looking good but on the short term we
have some
weakness guys all right we have some
weaknesses so
let's go through this press action
together and let's see what are the
good signals and the bad signals so the
first
bad signal that i see guys is that we
broke this all right
so this was giving us a nice bullish
hidden divergence market making higher
lows and the macd
going lower all right so on the farmers
i think we see it
no we don't have it on the flowers was
it on the daily so on the daily time
frame you see it the momentum indicator
is going lower guys
here and the price action is going
higher so this is a buddhist hidden
divergence right
this one as usual okay market making
higher lows
when the momentum is going down so which
means we are in a bearish
correction and still despite being in a
bearish correction we are not making new
lows
which means that the bears are not that
much in control as they think
but when this trend line here breaks
when we basically trade
below the trend line i'm very careful
and my
exit level when i use those kind of
signals is actually
the second low created by
the price action so it's here 135
so for me this bullish hidden divergence
would stop having an impact
if we break 125 now
let's go back on the 15 minutes time
frame so this is the first signal that i
have
but as you can see we broke already the
yellow line that is here
and we have retested it so let me
go through with you guys through this
whole collection that we're having here
so first here we have the beautiful one
two three four five
where we broke the red trend line here
around the 200 level
all right something like this 190 200 we
completed five beautiful waves that all
you know fit with the idiot wave theory
and then here you know
i changed the beat my lap linga
sometimes i call it w
x y sometimes i'm calling it a b c
it depends if the c wave has five waves
or not
here the c waves has definitely five
waves
as you can see so in this situation it's
not w
x y because w x y means that w
and y are three waves patterns
so here it's an abc but it doesn't
change much
the only thing that is changing is that
here we have this one two three four
five
and it's exactly the same situation as
we have for amc guys
i don't know if the fifth wave is going
here and this is a fourth and the third
is here one two three four five it's
possible you can see that here we can
find
easily five waves so to me it looks more
like
like this all right so maybe we're gonna
have
one more rejection at the 180 level and
we would go to the 145 level
that is a very strong support that is
created by this trend line yes
145 today and once again find some more
liquidity before strongly bouncing back
so
here i would be careful i would not
follow just like for amc guys
of course there is one possible scenario
that this and then the abc will be here
but this abc is complete guys that we
are
like this this is possible as well if
this is the case
what we want to see so this is some
training tips that i'm giving you for
monday session guys for the open
today first here we have this
first wave so we want to see five waves
guys so one two
three four five we want to see five
waves two two hundred at them
we want to break the 200 level it's like
this 180 level
is roughly the 4d level for amc all
right it's like seven
eight percent higher so we want to break
this we want to break it we want to have
a beautiful breakout
something like this you know as usual we
break it we test my retest is here a bit
ugly but
you get the idea guys okay something
like this with a beautiful retest
and here it's of course a very nice
buying opportunity
so you wait for the breakout and you buy
the retest this is what i will do
once again not financial advice here
guys and
here what is invalidating this scenario
and that is going to my preferred
scenario guys i need to tell you that
is if we break this 166
level i gave you this in my discord as
well guys go and check it out if you
have
not subscribed to my discord channel yet
everything is for free for now
so go and enjoy the free information i'm
sharing there i'm putting some daily
market updates for gamestop for amc
i'm analyzing any stock you guys want me
to analyze i'm giving you some
views about many many stocks so i
encourage you guys to go there
it's a very nice community where we have
a lot of very smart people guys so apes
say they're not smart i'm telling you
they are
because i can see some very good
analysis done by apes
and i'm very happy about what is
happening there i thank you all guys for
being there
for building this community with me i
hope we're gonna go very far together
so here what i want to say is that below
166
you need to be careful is just
comparable to
amc 34 level if we break it then we have
still 160
but most likely the one two should
happen
quickly if it's one two all right if we
go here it's probably
uh abc you know probably uh flat
or even zigzag you know
so if we break 1666 my scenario is that
here we're going to get rejected 118
or we even can go right away here so
those are my three different scenarios i
put them in my discord guys
so once again careful at 166 160 and you
want to see a break 180
and for the longer run what is going to
be the really bullish
signal is when we break this and we test
all right so guys we have time this is
what we want to see this is when it's
really time to
go long and buy anything you can once
again
not financial advice guys so guys this
is for me i hope you enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys